[Music]
[Applause]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Saki on
super excited to be talking about
radical social entrepreneurs we have
Michael strong joining us on the show
hello Thank You Alan great to be here
very blessed to have you I love your
mind your mental lattice so in the world
this is gonna be a lot of fun I'm
excited to be here sweet so let's give a
background to Michael strong for those
that don't know he has 28 years of
experience building out radically
innovative programs and schools K
through 12 based on Montessori
principles Socratic principles very
excitedly talking about that he's also
the founder of academy of thought and
industry he's also co-founder of
conscious capitalism and he's a two-time
author and so much more very excited to
unpack this let's start with the big
history perspective on civilization we
find ourselves as stewards of earth what
is your current take on the synthesis of
human experience so one of the things
I'm deeply fascinated about is the
concept of evolutionary mismatch we all
know that we were not designed to have
access to much as much fat and sugar as
we all have and as little physical
activity what we don't know or I don't
think people are thought lee aware of is
the evolutionary mismatch between our
kind of mind and social relationships so
you know I work with teens I see there's
an epidemic of adolescent dysfunction I
think the epidemic of adolescent
dysfunction including you know mental
illness eating disorders self-harm
suicide is all a symptom of a different
kind of evolutionary mismatch we evolved
being tribes or at the age of 1213 we'd
be part of the adult community you know
hunting our first deer or taking on
adult female responsibilities and we
were in a culture that had a sense of
virtue and honor and dignity and one
wanted to be you know do the right thing
in this culture
now we're scattered
or everything's mess so my deep interest
is the creation of healthy communities
sometimes I talk about what I do is
paleo education and it's funny I do know
people who are into you know I know John
Durant author of the paleo manifesto who
actually went out and you know did one
of those endurance hunting where after
three days they got a antelope but they
were too tired to actually kill it so
they exhausted the antelope they clapped
so I'm not paleo in that sense exactly
though I respect it but yeah I think
that young people need community the
kind of tight-knit community that was
necessary that we evolved in from
millions of years so super interested in
you know how in various ways that have
not made up and recognized evolutionary
mismatches responsible for the leading
public health crises of our time right
now a behavioral disorders including
substance abuse and mental illness
functional mental illness are the
largest causes of disability in the US
and rapidly spreading around the world
so we got a lot to fix what an
interesting term evolutionary mismatch
because we have such an abundance and
ubiquity and food now where it's just on
every single corner so often so many
meals so much obesity now more obese
people than starving people on the
planet what and then another interesting
though the Paleo Education bry was the
first time I heard that to your
nomenclature so cool I love your words
that you use these neologisms are so
important for creating new ways of
perception big time yes so ok so paleo
education is cool because you take these
first principles ways of thinking about
how to water a seed of mind right into
the world and you help the child fully
realize big history fully realize
critical thinking fully realize how
these technological devices hitting them
up 150 times a day can actually be more
cancerous to their creative and Deverick
so I'm gonna it's tricky because there's
one kind of way of looking at the world
actually I'm really fascinated with this
that oh one reading do you know who
Julian Jaynes is the
the origin of consciousness and the
breakdown the bicameral mind okay oh
you've got read Julian James
I think Julian Jane's fan in some ways
he interprets getting kicked out of the
Garden of Eden as this transition from
kind of the conch and the holistic
consciousness that we had prior to I
know the split mind but then so I'm a
big fan of Greek rationality and this is
where it gets tricky because I do think
that we had a social-emotional wholeness
prior to rational thought and to a great
extent the kind of rational thought that
really was coming out of the Socratic
interactions of ancient Athens have
ultimately led to the prosperity we have
today but at a tremendous cost yeah and
so my goal is how do we this goes back
to big history for the big cost big time
so how do we enjoy all the goodies of
Science and Technology you know hey I
want a warm shower in the morning yeah I
like hot showers yes you know and at the
same time there's an epidemic of misery
so how do we create subfolders knowledge
subculture so I'm about healthy
subcultures you know last time we went
we talked about you know circling and
mindfulness and the pasta and also just
healthy good relationships so I think we
evolved to be in Purpose Driven cultures
and you know indigenous cultures were
purposeful in the sense of survival
you know but that gave you a lot of
purpose you know my wife some synagogue
I got wage she was on your show and in
Senegal it's not you know fully
indigenous anymore but the adolescents
there's not the epidemic of adolescent
dysfunction there and I see tragic
numbers of kids you know just self-harm
cutting you know a poor culture they're
not out cutting themselves you know
they're out working hard they're part of
their communities they respect their
elders so there's a really complicated
transition going from the kind of social
emotional and wellness then but abject
poverty and half or more the babies died
and no warm showers now we've got all
the goodies but we're miserable not all
of us I'm happy I think you're happy you
know but we've found purpose and
community so how can we the next new
technology I love my iPhone but the next
new technology are subcultures of
happiness well-being sometimes I
describe myself as an entrepreneur of
happiness
well being know yeah we've got enough
stuff most people in the developed world
have more than enough stuff so even even
materialism my perception is that you
know there are the you know
environmentalists who want to kind of
preach in a sort of puritanical way
about don't be so materialistic I'm like
no instead let's satisfy our social
emotional needs and our purpose needs in
warm rich communities of purpose and I
don't need stuff you know warm shower
but other you know I think it's all sort
of embarrassing people that need big
cars and stuff like I'm sorry sorry dude
that you have those you know they're
always jokes about the little penises
whatever if you have why do you need
eight women twerking around you to feel
like you're yeah if you're Purpose
Driven and socially emotionally well you
don't need a lot of stuff Massholes
Harker hierarchy got it let's self
actualize and do good in the world and
have fun so ultimately I'm in that sense
when everybody to have a blast spending
all day every day
doing good and enjoying it and feeling
like there's nothing more delightful in
helping other human beings by these are
our projects yes yes okay holy cow
alright so there's there's two things
just quick to touch on there first your
fascination with communities I just love
how much you care about that and yes as
we talked about these these little sub
culture pockets like the vasanas and yes
circlings and also like you said we have
so much stuff now we've and these on
your big history perspective of society
you say that this social-emotional
wholeness then we had took them took a
back seat to the technological
scientific explosion which now there's
so much stuff there's so much ubiquity
there's so much excess information but
we're not structuring that data
structuring that knowledge making our
communities in our social emotional
well-being also a priority at the same
time so that's kind of the next essence
the next generational way of thinking is
meaning to include those two halves
together big time and no you know I
hesitate to call it information because
then again I focused on adolescence I
think when I look at the dysfunction of
adult society I spend a lot of time with
middle schoolers I love middle schoolers
and they're challenging I look at our
adult society is middle schoolers all
over the place you know Donald Trump is
a mean 7th grader in
so if we can help people transition out
of the Lord of the Flies stage you know
the William Golding author of Lord of
the Flies was a middle school teacher he
knows what you know kids are like
without the right healthy virtue
community it's so in to create healthy
virtue communities where these young
people of incredible energy and
plasticity yeah and right now all that
energy and plasticity is being consumed
by digital media gaming porn social
media bullying teens saying [ __ ] about
each other online yeah and consumers
materialism what what sneakers am i
wearing and what you know all that stuff
but instead if we give them a sense of I
want to be excellent in this culture in
this way because you know I want to seek
the truth I want to seek the glitter
whatever and so to that extent I'm also
extremely culturally an adverse in the
sense that although I'm very much an
intellectual I respect military schools
or Catholic schools or Jewish schools or
whatever where they're you know creating
a healthy subculture where kids needs
are made mad I don't care what the
subculture is as long as they're not
harming other people correct and as long
as we're helping young people develop in
a healthy way and as long civilization
is going towards that harmonious truth
with with each other and with nature and
aligning really well to that prosperity
to that pinnacle point that we can we
can actually be which I really also I'm
just such I'm so I adored the way that
you talk about giving the seeds of
children nutrients and seeing what can
happen when they pursue truth that the
greatest excellence or pursue good at
the greatest excellence yeah and so much
of the mind of the neuro real estate the
limited biological infrastructure we
have here is consumed on the materialism
it consumed on the digital media side of
things so your focus in the last 28
years hustling on this is fascinating to
me and we were already obviously seeing
that come come through you right now
it's so cool so I don't think enough
people get want to sori get Socratic
understandings of what that means for K
through 12 education teach us about how
youth applying those principles in to us
absolutely I'll start with the socratic
piece because that's where I started so
you know right now you and I are talking
about ideas so Socratic fancy word but
we're talking about ideas we're having
fun talking about ideas you have fun
doing this that's the whole inspiration
for your channel I have fun doing this I
selfishly create schools because it's
fun you know and I think once people get
into the world of talking about ideas
it's a blast
you know sometimes I've had teachers ask
is this appropriate for all learning
styles and I point to a lunchroom and
kids are brought along human beings are
made to talk you know that's and talk
about you know evolutionary we involved
talk and there's a lot there's a lot
going on there so then the question is
how do we make talk you know relevant
important I'm very fascinated with
Jewish culture Jewish culture for 2500
years they've been arguing about ideas I
mean basically I once had a rabbi coming
to one of my Socratic classrooms even he
said that's just what we did in Talmudic
school this is a great new image of
school I want to break everybody's
notion of what a school is I actually
have an essay called ten school science
which is way out there but that this
Talmudic school he said that the
students would argue all day in
isolation all week and then on Fridays
they take apart the red velvet curtain
and then get asked the rabbi one
question
teacher-student ratio you know the rabbi
is alone and the kids are you know the
young adults are arguing all the time
and then they asked rabbi one question
so that's my idea
okay you guys go do it and you know I'll
let chespin
but arguing thinking about ideas I map
lightness you know the true that would
in a beautiful how do we pursue the
truth we've been good in the beautiful
in our conversation so when I was in
high school I had a teacher and that's
all we did instead regular school you
know we talk about ideas we read Boober
and Nietzsche and Plato and so forth
and for me it was like you know those
films where it goes from black and white
to color all of a sudden life was in
color and for me the rest of school was
incredibly dull so you know at this
point I described
conventional secondary school as seven
years of boredom and cruelty that's an
adult I'm never bored as I was in school
and if people are jerks I don't hang out
with them and so why all is torture when
there's this fun thing you can do so
then I was I discovered st. John's
College great books College Santa Fe New
Mexico for four years all you do is
you can talk about books all you do so
there no lecture classes I was talked
into going to Harvard because look you
can study Greek and Plato and so forth
but famous people talking about me
boring so I went to st. John's for years
talk about ideas and then I wanted to
share this with kids so Mortimer Adler
he wrote how to read a book I was under
his program in Chicago and his training
teachers and students I'd never had a
background note not one class in
education by the experience doing the
Socratic thing so I went into classrooms
and would train teachers how to lead a
Socratic conversations with kids it was
like lighting a fire in a gas tank the
kids were relieved eventually when I
read wrote my books a habit of thought
it was because that was the first time a
group of students came to me and they
said this is the first time an adult has
ever listened to me they said our
parents don't listen to us our bosses
don't listen to us our teachers don't
listen to us our ministers don't listen
to us but basically the very simplest
version of Socratic is I say something
you think about it listen and respond
and a lot of what I trained students to
do is one person's says something about
we read a text together we talk about it
I ask questions my whole role as a
leader is to ask questions just like
you're asking questions and it sounds
simple but students rarely have the
experience of just engaging an
intellectual dialogue and once they get
it it can be hard to transition I've
been in classrooms where it's a really
hard to get there and part of the
artistry of doing this is dealing with a
huge range of students but once they get
there they have fun the school in Austin
I created the students would have
Socratic after school for fun they had
online class Socratic dialogues over the
summer for fun once you get the bug of
talking about ideas it's a way of life
know with m'god on our first day I was
asking her questions all the time he
says oh this is noise this is not going
so well but eventually she loved it now
she and I talked about ideas all the
time you know again once you get hooked
so that for me the Socratic piece is
let's create an intellectually rich
culture and so my whole thing is
creating a subculture everybody else is
like Oh school is curriculum and
pedagogy and assessment
yeah all of that stuff exists but for me
the essence is what is the culture for
me the school is only successful when
the kids are starting to talk about
ideas outside of class when it's
for them when it matters to them and
then at that point then you've got an
intellectual subculture they read they
write they think and learning happens
conversely they need to go to back to
the Montessori piece so Maria Montessori
a hundred years ago first Italian doctor
in Italy first female Italian doctor in
Italy and she was sent to work with kids
with issues and she developed this
method where it's based on student
autonomy so if you go to and every every
person should go see him on our story
preschool you see these little
four-year-olds walking around the room
you know perfect proposal II doing their
work they look like they're completely
adults and it's cool to see these tiny
little kids Maria Montessori said the
greatest sign of success of a teacher is
when the students are act are acting
just the same when you're not there so
any class I would say any class where
the teacher needs to be there for the
kids to be learning is not yet a
successful class I said that's 99.9% of
schools in America so Montessori is huge
emphasis on autonomy and accountability
and we carry those principles into the
secondary level Maria Montessori did not
create a secondary model one essay about
farm school which is great but in
addition to the Socratic piece where we
create rich intellectual culture we
support radical student autonomy with
respect to cool projects I want students
to do real-world projects we had a kid
in Austin who book was a band concert
promoter so he was booking bands booking
venues selling tickets made about 6,000
bucks in 10th grade by the time he
graduated from high school he had a
three day music festival Austin terror
fest which he co-founded he'd booked 200
bands by the time he's a high school
senior now if you can do stuff like that
yeah let's just go do it and get him
going back to the traditional society
creating Austin Terra Fest may not look
very paleo but taking on adult level
responsibilities of doing real world
things that are meaningful and not just
you know high school assignment you know
if it's just an exercise for the teacher
it's not happening it has to be
meaningful in their social and cultural
system and with respect to their long
term goals and so that's kind of
autonomy and accountability as
Montessori is a deep intellectual
culture is kradic and then ultimately
Purpose Driven and warm supportive
community so we create this little paleo
subculture adapted for 21st century you
know creative entrepreneur
you know beans and kids do what they do
because they love it I know you do what
you love but because you love what you
do I do what I love I love what I do
why can't we develop subcultures where
teams love what they do and do what they
love yes
to think that there's so many nutrients
that are being helped with the seeds
that are growing that are the nutrients
densities or arrays of nutrients are
lacking to those seeds because like you
said how can you have an actual
classroom where the teacher needs to be
present instructing all the time the
Socratic method of them and having
discourse these these two words nuance
and equanimity I think are so important
in the Socratic yeah dialogue this
method because one needs to have the
multivariate perspective there's so many
variables happening that we're talking
about so it's not binary and also the
equanimity that I'm even though your
opinion is gonna differ from mine then
I'm gonna stay calm and still engage and
be pleasant and all that kind of stuff
so those two things with Socratic and
then with Montessori that the they're
gonna be accountable to want to to want
to learn you're there the ice funny
Monday through Friday that imagining
just coming in with a bunch of other
people your age and having discourse
about critical thinking like how to
govern Mars right so something right
what protocols do you take from Earth
civilization and what do you bring to
Mars is civilization right and they have
to bump up up up up up up yeah Monday
through Friday they from like whatever
time they arrive to whatever time they
leave and then they come up you know
they're designing their own ideas and
logic stuff and you peel back the
curtain on Friday ask one question
yeah but I think one of the things is
all this sounds nice and it is really
hard to get going once you get it going
then it runs automatically but this is
why I'm interested in culture because
again in Jewish culture you don't need
to talk kids into talking about ideas
they've been hearing you know not all
these are generalizations but they've
been hearing I come from a working-class
you know Protestant family it was
considered rude you know ask questions
Realtors when I came back from st.
John's to talk to my grandfather over
the Christmas holidays my first year I
was asking him questions like this I
wouldn't have fun with him and he was
like why are you harassing me again in
many cultures it's considered radically
inappropriate interesting
that's behavior and so I'm extremely
interested in this for social mobility
because I think there's some subcultures
where it's normal to be intellectual and
other subcultures and I'm not blaming
those every culture adapted to its
particular circumstances and that's fine
but you know we need to kind of crank it
up if those kids would have a great life
so this whole thing I'm very
deliberately culture grading when I go
into a new environment with kids and
things like uh I couldn't really how do
we disagree so we don't get pissed off
at each other and sometimes some regular
teachers look at they listen sounds
great but you know there are sometimes
emotional explosions and one of the
reasons we use a text is to make a more
distant
I often with the new group might have
say a mathematics text because if I
started on a political subject you know
fights right away and so there are
different ways in which you know we very
carefully cultivate the kind of
interaction that you know you and I you
know we're already immersed in the water
we don't even know we're swimming in the
water now but most people are not yet
there and especially many kids from
households where it's not the norm we
have to bring them in very carefully
okay
um this is kind of this is our perfect
segue and into what you're doing because
Academy of thought in industry you the
way that you're proposing this
transition is very fascinating to me
because like you said there's different
socio-economic statuses there's
different parental involvement sand
they're engaging of their children's
full creative potential yeah so there's
these different variables that need to
be balanced if you drop a political
subject right away into a really
disruptive classroom it'll be really
tough to make this happen if you somehow
slowly ease them into it with a
non-political subject so yeah so teach
us about this process of kind of like
easing the these kids and you have two
schools right now Boston in San
Francisco and those are roaring and
you're gonna have New York and st. Louis
by August yeah if 2019 which is very
exciting so this is yeah it's about yeah
so um first I their various things that
I think prevent parents from being
comfortable doing this and I I want to
democratize this so I do a weekly
YouTube call with
six-year-old I have been working with
her since she's four so I can kind of
model this because once you know how to
do it it's easy the trick is getting
there so for instance one of the things
one of the way I always approach it is I
want to know what you think and not just
you I want to know Alana's the
six-year-old I don't know what Alana
thing so in a recent call I was asking
her about she was in a shoe store and
her dad just gets the iPhone and we
start talking and you know I know she
knows say what 20-15 is and so I was
asking her about you know how when you
buy something and you pay money you know
how do they give you change how do you
know wouldn't give you change I don't
think she had ever thought about this
again she's six but I want to know how
does I was not didactically trying to
teach her anything I was not
manipulating her into any kind of an
answer I don't know what's inside her
brain I want to know her reality I want
to see the world through the eyes of the
six-year-old and because she trusts that
I'm not there to be didactic or
manipulative that I honestly care you
know I see her and I want to understand
her mind and with all my students I want
to say how do you see the world and then
I asked them questions since they get to
explain it if they think that I'm going
to be didactic or manipulative and this
is a problem with conventional education
in a regular classroom the teacher has a
destination and so Oh Alan I think
that's a nice thought you've got about -
killing a mockingbird but it's really
about this or you know their questions
are always manipulative and I'm not
saying every teacher is but the standard
format of a standard class is we are
teaching a lesson and by the end of the
lesson you need to know this I'm not
I've radically rejected that I'm not
saying you need to know anything you
know we might be reading something
together but how do you make sense of
this paragraph how do you you know what
what counts as justice how do you know
it's just how do I had a girl in a class
recently who's a big advocate of
political violence that's interesting
how do you know when it's appropriate to
be violent politically and when not you
know I think you know she's an anarchist
and she thought oh the teacher is gonna
be freaked out there's some advocating
violence no look you know tell me about
it let's talk about it I want to learn
about it behind them and other students
then oh my gosh but then they they want
to know - okay well and some you know if
if there is slavery do the slaves have a
right to be violent to the masters you
know at what point you know it doesn't
become genocide there are all sorts of
interesting
you know at first she was advocating for
the Nazis then she realized well I don't
want to advocate for the Nazis you know
these kids have to think through these
things so I see it as let's find a way
where we don't get pissed off at each
other to try to understand each other's
ideas you know again when I say I say X
use listen and reply a thoughtful you
that implies that when I say you know
maybe we should you know engage in
political violence mmm that's
interesting why and when and where and
how without kind of freaking out you
know oh you believe that an unborn child
you know should be aborted and I think
that's a human life they should know
that's interesting you know I'm kind of
exaggerating because just because in an
adult life people are you know in some
ways ready to kill each other of these
issues but if we want to have a
civilized conversation we need to be
able to think through these things
before we get to a destructive point
David Boehm was a famous 20th century
through theoretical physicist has a
wonderful book on dialogue where he
calls this at a public scale socio
therapy so just like individual
psychotherapy might be necessary to kind
of figure out who we are what's going on
so Co therapy is we have such different
worldviews how can we talk in a
civilized way to kind of work through
them
you know that's how I love how you go
into behind the eyes of the young person
and again you're not aiming to
manipulate you're aiming to understand
you're not saying that this is one right
answer you're saying that how can you
understand their worldview and ask an
interesting question that gets them to
expand their awareness of the
understanding of reality that they're in
mm-hmm I have I pulled up the you know
the thought in industry calm sight here
and what's cool is that you know you're
getting you have your high school for
teens who want to excel on their own
terms that this is a this sentence here
is about you creatively flourishing this
is not you fitting into a high school
box right that we know that this is
exactly what is right now there are
certain aspects though that I wanted to
kind of like ask you about in the sense
of like you know you want a seed mm-hmm
that isn't being molded into the world
to understand the big history
perspective on a reality you want them
to realize that a hundred billion humans
built the civilization before us and for
them to really get that so get that
gratitude that we all vault you're on
justice rock how do you ask the right
questions to are so there are some
things in this box that we can say of
like knowledge that are important so
it's like on your own terms but you have
to know the big history that's a really
interesting tension so first of all by
nature it sounds like as if you are in
that sense more didactic than I am Alan
has a ginge in it you have to know that
big history so part of this is you know
because you know I'm operating in this
u.s. culture one of the most common
destinations for students obviously is
College and in order to prepare students
for college in to do well at college um
you know for instance it's useful to
know world history and it's useful to
know biology and so forth and so the
instead of me saying this is what you
should know you know I explained to them
as a coach so my whole orientation is
more coaching them and it is useful to
be an educated adult if somebody for
some reason really
does not want to that's a different
conversation I'll give you an example in
a math but um you know for most students
who are going to college things like
biology including deep evolutionary
biology and world history including
going from evolutionary biology to
what's usually called their ancient
history so big history fits in quite
nicely with anybody who's college bound
and it makes it more interesting and
relevant and so rather than you need to
know big history like look if you want
to be an educated person you really need
to know you know biology and history
this is a cool way to think about it and
I I personally fascinated by a no
evolutionary biology evolutionary
mismatch evolutionary psychology I think
it's just a cool way to understand the
world so the other thing is I can be in
addition to the utilitarian this is
what's useful for college there's also
the as a witness as it were that is
these things fascinate me personally
separately from that going back to
students who may not want the whole
standard high school curriculum
um I've had I get a lot of creatives who
maybe want to be filmmakers designers
that kind of thing and what's more
common you know I haven't had a real
fight over say history so much over time
that becomes relevant a lot of them
don't want to do a lot of math yeah yeah
Picasso could barely do arithmetic he
turned out okay
yes so I for instance had a design
student who one was going to Parsons
School of Design who didn't want to take
algebra 2 and his parents were okay with
that I was okay as that no problem you
don't need algebra too so I would say
we're willing to kind of craft things
for an individual basis that's
interesting yeah you know I'm that said
ultimately I don't demand that every
student you know has to have X I'm very
pragmatic of you know I'll say something
like if you don't know you know you'll
come across as an idiot you know yeah I
I'm not saying you need to know this but
people do they evaluate you on how you
address on you know how you speak the
English language how you write and if
you come across as ignorant it'll show
you know if that's one yeah be well okay
so tackling this tension seems to be
probably the hardest
thing that's that's going on with
academy of thought and industry because
you want to do your best to have them
beyond their terms right learning is on
your terms I want to be excellent in
your own terms
yeah at the same time you want to to
know like how to because you can't
actually talk right without knowing
language and without knowing a big tall
man without so things like you know
reading writing speaking skills are
incredibly important so part of this is
you know you were in sales I'm a
salesman for these things that I believe
are important and then unapologetic
salesman so just to be articulate I
explained to them that if you are really
articulate you will have so many
benefits in life and actually much more
important than doing well on a history
or bio test is to be articulate um you
know if you can write well this is from
my personal life very often in meetings
all offer to write up the notes of the
meeting because its strategic he who
writes up what happened to that meeting
just controlled that meeting you know
different case I've done very well with
cold called emails so you know I worked
with John Mackey CEO of Whole Foods
originally that's do a cold call email
to gary Hoover's fellow entrepreneur so
one of the things I talked to students
about is how to write emails to somebody
you don't know yes and it's not just
about grammar and punctuation again
sales how do you get inside somebody
else's heads so you can be persuasive um
Zak's lay back was kind of a brilliant
writer on this but those sorts of things
they get that so I'm not telling them
you need to know the date of the
American Revolution anyway if you don't
you will come across as an idiot but
more broadly you know if you want to be
effective at a certain level you need
these skills and you know they they
certainly respect Maya and I'd give them
a lot of real-world stories one of
things I ask is that our teachers have
some real-world experience because it
turns out that the quadratic you know
the equation might not be useful in most
real-world situations but reading and
writing effectively and being broadly
informed about the world pretty
important than a lot of situations
this tension is so hard for me to wrap
my self around because I'm all about
like the right nutrients for the seeds
right and you're and you're also about
that while simultaneously being about
letting the seeds go and I'm also about
that letting them explore on their terms
so this is just such an interesting
point about I'm glad we got here
so let me give you another piece and
this is a big difference between me and
you know many educators so one of the
biggest fears about say school choice is
that some schools won't teach evolution
and evolution is a really big part of my
worldview that said I think the the
health and well-being of teens is much
more important than evolution so I'm
perfectly happy to allow for you know
say religious schools that don't teach
about evolution and thus from your and
my perspective they might be wacko from
a scientific perspective but if teens
are not killing themselves or cutting
that's okay with me and part of this too
is I have faith that over time you know
the truth will in out in education will
in out and at this point with the
internet you know you can't keep
somebody in a box they'll find out about
everything so I think those sort of
old-style fears are gradually going and
the health and well-being sign becomes
more important and the fact is to
because you teach something in school
doesn't mean that anybody learned it
that's one of the biggest delusions
delusions of our time we need to teach
the kids X give you an example about but
languages yes yeah but kind of going to
concrete knowledge curve the fewer than
one about 23 percent of American adults
can name the three branches of
government but listen 23 percent yeah so
you say Oh public ignorance but it turns
out we should teach that it is being
taught it has been taught if you look at
state standards it's required to teach
yeah at both middle school and high
school so we are teaching it one of my
metaphors when are they for those
watching at home legislative judicial
and executive there you go thank you for
the course but a lot of there's a lot of
educational is like throwing spaghetti
against the wall it all comes down how
do you get the spaghetti to stick to a
wall if it's meaningless I just
it has memorize and forget tests I was
great at you know memorizing the night
before the test get in my a walking out
you know I got an A in high school on
the parts of a frog could I fill out a
diagram on the parts of her frog today
no idea turns out in medical education
which is really high stakes doctors
forget about 50% of what they learned
the previous year and they only retain
about 30% long time so most of us forget
most of what we learn in most
educational circumstances where
literally I were taking a value it's an
every piece of knowledge that we gain
based on our worldview of retaining that
knowledge we're prioritizing the
retention of that knowledge because we
find it important or we find it
unimportant to retain it and so when you
kind of lead on your own terms
yeah you assign in the sense greater
desire to learn the things that you're
focused on that way you're actually
potentially retaining more of the
knowledge that you're learning I would
add one other piece to that which is
social emotional connections basically
Judith rich Harris one of my favorite
authors talks about how teens are much
more influenced by peers than they are
by adults including parents but also
teachers and so when the way I'm looking
at solving this problem is not trying to
get them to care about something I
create a subculture where it's normal to
talk about evolution yeah which is
normal to talk about history is where
it's normal to try to understand modern
problems in the and you know if it's
normal for kids to argue even if kid a
who really hates history really hates
biology doesn't care at all maybe comes
from a religious household where they
reject this but all his or her friends
are arguing about this of course they'll
do it the fact is you know it turns out
telling kids not to smoke
not very effective if they hang out with
kids at smokes they're probably smoker
they hang out with kids that don't smoke
then they probably debating the multi
variability of smoking there we go on to
each other there we go there we go
that's a good one
so in that same thing can be applied to
the potential addictions that we have to
food into social media etc that if the
kids are talking about oh well you know
I feel this way when I
too much or when I eat food that's not
healthy or I feel this way when I'm
obsessively on digital media versus then
you can get them talking with each other
about you know Sam feels that way and
Paula feels this way it's cetera totally
and even you know to go to a great
example from my perspective so many
people regard a Hungarian mathematics is
in the 20th century is one of the
greatest achievements in all of
mathematics Hungary produced yeah
exactly there were a lot of amazing
Hungarian mathematicians it turns out
that late 19th early 20th century hungry
had this kind of competitive system
where teens in high schools would
compete for math prizes and then they
also had a culture where they were
talking and arguing about math problems
so a Hungarian the amazingness of 20th
century Hungarian mathematics I see is
the direct result of a very distinctive
subculture created by a relatively small
number of schools where it became
normalized to think talk and argue about
math problems all the time yeah that's
so interesting that you can identify the
sub cultural excellence to the route
which was their ability and desire to
incentivize with prized systems which is
a really good way I think to incentivize
learning and and passion for
entrepreneurship and so many other
things solving problems and also just
the discourse ok so we spent a good
amount of time on that tension side of
things which is which is really exciting
to me and so now how many how many total
kids are with all moss in San Francisco
right now we have about 50 kids and
probably next year we have 70 or so so
you know with small little communities
do any subcultures I want to keep it at
Robin Dunbar an evolutionary biologist
Dunbar's number you know we evolved in
communities yeah 150 or so and so all
communities small I think one of the
problems with the large you know public
high school 3,000 kids they don't have
that sense of connection with you know
100 kids or so we can create a virtue
subculture and part of this is when you
become larger you need more rules
I know high school principals that spend
all our time measuring girls skirts is
that skirt you know X inches exactly
ridiculous but in a subculture we don't
have a lot of rules we create norms and
if there's an issue you know does this
count as being too Reuters
let's talk about it very different from
top-down rules yeah and this is all K
through 12 no no we're just a high
school so this is so there's higher
ground education as a requirement
company they're a leading organization
modernized and in scaling Montessori
okay and so they've got about thirty
Montessori schools across the US and
then we are as a high school branch so
again Maria Montessori didn't create a
secondary school middle school is kind
of in a transitional phase we are
developing middle school programs so
ultimately we'll have kids going all the
way from pre-k Montessori through ATI
high schools okay cool so so the the
this four-year-old that you were
illustrating that was like you know the
teachers out of the room there's
throwing and right being accountable for
their own learning yeah what not so that
would be part of the higher ground
education right and that's part of the
Montessori school system up until eighth
grade and then the Academy thought
industry et is your high school model
model of yeah so then they go all the
way the pre-k through 12 right um do
that system and then here's something an
important question to address here so
thank you Ron so one of the things that
I think is you know let's let's we'll
write up on this quick and then so we
can get to the other stuff but just it's
it's tough sometimes for there are
scholarships all right to those in low
SES right right because these are more
on the the public school right of cost
right right part of the taxpayers and
right state etc versus a Montessori
system and each item costs yeah what is
it about tens of thousands per yeah it's
differently based on the city it's you
know more expensive in New York San
Francisco cheaper in Austin and st.
Louis that kind of thing but so I'm very
interested in scaling this making it
cheaper I see it as fundamental get
people to realize it's really about
culture that's the number one thing so I
have an article out there how to give
your child an expensive private
education for $3,000 a year and a lot of
it is developing these norms and
interactive interaction which sounds
strange because again everybody thinks
it's all curriculum and so forth but I
think one of the problems with schooling
as we know it is it gives people a wrong
of what matters in education and nobody
is talking about developing the right
habits and attitudes and creating
subcultures so my wife and I have a
school in Senegal and they're you know
first of all I am a big fan of students
teaching students and not only teaching
but developing the subculture so I'm
most delighted when instead of adult
teachers basically most adult teachers
have been trained to teach if I create a
Socratic subculture where it's normal
for kids to be arguing about ideas they
can help each other and so our school in
Senegal the basic model is older kids
thinking talking arguing with younger
kids and that's a way to scale this up
really cheaply to give you one concrete
example 200 years ago there was a system
of education founded by Joseph Lancaster
a working-class British kid 18 Annie
create a system with teacher-student
ratios of 1 to 100 1 to 500 and
sometimes one to a thousand which sounds
ridiculous but it's all students
teaching students teaching students
teaching students and so in some ways if
we create subcultures where it's normal
for kids to learn and teach then we
don't need teachers and it sounds crazy
but this is you know you don't have to
teach you know teens the latest slang
words they teach each other the slang
words you know how much are how can we
spend more money to get more people no
that just happens so this is the magic
if we can find a way and this is kind of
the frontier where I'm working if we can
find a way to normalize productive
activity is natural pure interaction
yeah cheap and it's free basically it
becomes free free because then you have
the kids in their free time obsessing
about wanting to talk to each other
about ideas exactly and build those and
create those exactly and we know in
terms I'm not saying so you know methane
meta in Greek is that which can be
taught and so I would say math and stem
is different and there's teaching but
kids can still teach each other um we
have students working on Khan Academy a
great resource but the key there is to
train the students to help each other
with the math so then it becomes so
right now most people we're all excited
about online learning online learning is
gonna change the world I would say
online learning changes the world if and
only if you
subculture were teens or kids even young
kids can take advantage of it so a
people excited about technology have not
realized that we need the human
technology to complement the other
technology in order to create free
education for the whole world so my
specialty in some ways is articulating
and developing these human systems that
then will allow for free education to be
a reality around the world you you have
that vision that I love so much I agree
that this is going to become more and
more of a common place to see young
people wanting to have the discourses
about ideas and in making a common place
will be so fun seeing four six eight ten
twelve year olds working on talking
about these ideas and building them out
this is will be very fun I'm glad you're
at the cutting edge of this I want to
ask you because you're at the cutting
edge of a lot of other thinking as well
especially in law governance right so
this is kind of this is kind of like we
see little pockets of things happening
we see the United States doing its thing
we see China doing its thing
and see some other stuff happening in
like Singapore yeah so we teach us about
your thoughts around so let me give you
a bit more context so yeah almost 20
years ago now I met John Mackay CEO fall
foods founder co-founder and CEO of
Whole Foods I had created a bunch of
schools he create a bunch of grocery
stores we agreed that we believed in
entrepreneurial solutions to world
problems and ultimately be the solution
how entrepreneurs and conscious
capitalists can solve all the world's
problems was the outcome of that but at
the time kind of looking at things you
know social entrepreneurship was cool
micro entrepreneurship was cool tech
entrepreneurship was cool but I started
digging more deeply and realized in a
lot of ways the biggest problem is
global poverty and if we can help people
become prosperous the first SDG what
what a win so you know if you know you
started looking into it it turns out
that people are poor in most countries
because of bad law and governance and if
we can create or find a way to allow
them to access world-class law and
governance then they become prosperous
and just you know economic growth
tackles
corruption and greed and gluttony at the
same time well maybe not greed and
gluttony corruption it turns out as a
substantial portion of corruption is
because poor countries are over
regulated almost nobody gets this
actually I'm working with the Rosling
they have a fact fulness sight and
that's one of those things where almost
nobody understands this the the
anti-capitalist have said oh you know
the developing world has no regulations
and that's why they're people our
companies are going there certainly in
China the special economic zones had
almost no regulation for a period of
time and more people escaped poverty
more quickly than ever before in history
so just important data point in China
1980
even to 1990 average GDP per capita
including and roughly average wages for
about a thousand dollars per person
now it's somewhere between six to ten
thousand dollars per person depending on
which numbers you believe nobody trusts
Chinese government numbers but no doubt
people have become massively prosperous
China is rapidly becoming a middle-class
Society again in Africa it's still about
a thousand dollars per person and so you
know in China in the last 20-30 years
almost a billion people have gone from
poor to by a global standards middle
class and they've done it because the
special economic zones allowed for rapid
economic prosperity meanwhile most
developing countries have terrible law
and governance massively over-regulated
weak property rights and as a
consequence you know in Africa yeah Maga
and I talked about it's like swimming
through molasses to get anything done
you know to get a building building
permit to start a business to you know
import goods it's just really hard so
this whole movement when I when I
started flow with John Mackey's that was
what flow was conscious capitalism was
one of its descendants we were looking
at okay how do we how do we accelerate
prosperity MIT Mark Fraser a brilliant
guy who's who had been involved in the
economic special economic zone industry
and he said look these zones are way for
fast growth and he cited not only China
where it's famous but zones developed
into
helped develop rapid growth in Mauritius
Mexico in Ireland you know many
countries around the world but then it's
matter designing there's some horrible
zones out there then you get into the
nuance of how do you design zones and it
turns out one of the most important
things and hardest import is high
quality law and governance so Dubai is
an interesting innovator there where
Dubai wanted to be a financial center
they have Sharia law and you know no
interest that's not cool for big finance
so they created a zone a hundred and ten
acres for the Dubai International
Financial Center where within 110 acres
it's British common law they actually
had a higher de prestigious London
commercial law judge and then Singapore
which is also British common law
commercial law judge now they have a
panel of you know maybe 30 respected
judges from around the world and if you
you know if you wouldn't be Citibank or
Goldman Sachs and you're in the D IFC
your law is not Sharia law in Dubai it's
basically a London law world-class
financial hub it turns out all the best
financial centers run British common law
Hong Kong Singapore London New York
Chicago Sydney all British common law
countries it's the best think of it as a
technology again yes very interesting as
were soft technologies so I love my
iPhone in education and creating new
cultures as a technology this is let's
take the best of cloths legal system if
for finance its London then let's plunk
it in Dubai and in 20 years Dubai has
gone from basically no financial
industry to being a top ten just this
year top 10 global financial hub pretty
incredible so so incredible any years no
in ten years to become a top ten ten
years from top ten which is unheard of
and so you can take the code yeah this
technology yeah of a British common law
and plunk it into an area and then see
what happens when people from around the
world want to come and partake in this
and it's also interesting hearing about
30 judges from around the world from
these hubs partaking in that because
that's what you'd want right you would
want a very strong international way of
because these are internationally acting
organizing
businesses and entities yeah taking it
international no no big time it's been
just couple of foot yeah so so this is
so successful that Abu Dhabi is kind of
copied at wholesale just a couple years
ago and Honduras has legislation to
allow for this and they were looking at
importing Dubai
the Dubai version of British common law
into Honduras you know and so the way I
see this growing is the old special
economic zones
yeah brought you know billion more than
a billion people out of poverty um but
those didn't address this legal system
issue the Dubai innovation is to create
a new legal system and plop it down and
you know I'm talking to various
countries in Africa
yeah yes so you imagine all these
African countries say was you know
terrible corruption and bad law if we
can successfully kind of plug in high
quality law and one of as you say one of
the important things about the justices
is we trust not only the law but also
the judges to produce good law yeah and
so if we can do this successfully I see
global poverty being reduced from very
rapidly and it even gets into the
immigration issue right now you know
both in Europe and in the u.s. there are
all of these really pretty
anti-immigrant party is racist frankly
parties coming into being because of all
the opposition to immigration whatever
one thinks about that if we can create
great places with great jobs for them to
live at home you know a Hondurans will
stay home the Africans will stay at home
and they'll be prosperous and at some
point you know we'll have this global
cosmopolitan world where right now you
know a lot of people want to move to
Singapore or Hong Kong
Dubai's trick here for a lot of reasons
but you know we we have now have this
kind of global approach to we want world
class law and governance everywhere so
that we can create entrepreneurial value
wherever we are and repetitive poverty
through that and then piece to piece in
rust that exactly of wherever you want
around the world and there will still be
big chunks of bad governance but the
more we can kind of create these islands
in some ways as a vision of the world
becoming city-states and the nation
state becomes obsolete
you know fastest-growing entities in the
last 50 years Hong Kong and Singapore
Shenzhen
special economic zone across from Hong
Kong just surpassed Hong Kong and GDP
per capita not GP total GDP yeah so you
know part of this vision is lots of
little city-states or zones whatever and
ultimately we eliminate poverty and then
you know on the education side then we
create happiness and well-being instead
of because I'll acknowledge a lot of the
first phase thing is pure greed so there
will be there's kind of an ugliness
about that phase of development that's
because there's no real judges and law
that is holding the authoritarian
dictators from from killing dissidents
and and stripping away resources for
just themselves all these different
types of things so when you have when
you have an earth that has these 8
billion people and then you have these
islands of the city-states that slowly
flourish and people say that's the long
governance we want the world-class long
governance then the whole earth becomes
that that will be very exciting see I
like your little of use added another
piece so eager meant and this is where
it becomes closer to technology hard
technology so you know Estonia is one of
the world's leaders in government one of
the things that you know we're actually
looking at piloting in Africa is suppose
we had government where it was
completely transparent every receipt
going into government yes every payment
going out was something that you or I
could audit so if you were not sure what
you know the mayor of the town was doing
or whatever a politician is doing you
just go online and audit it or you know
business registration you know in the US
you can get online and create an LLC in
no time at all in Africa it takes you
know months of you know meetings and
business and payments and bribes and all
that it's a mess so imagine if
everything was as easy to do as your
favorite online business and all law and
governance services were you know you
check your app okay start at a business
ok building permit they come in maybe
the drone flies over checks this out and
sometimes you need humans but imagine
governance is a technology and we have
the current state of our governments are
you know basically the Internet in
nineteen
and we see this glow all the cool
innovators crate these cool apps where
ultimately old-style governments fades
into the past and we have fully
transparent auditable of functional
government around the world and they're
competing so that yeah exactly
you know some of this is you may like
Singapore government whereas I think you
know it's too hard asked I may like San
Francisco you know freedoms and you know
maybe you're from Dubai and you know
whatever so la pluie Safra you know we
want everybody to do what they do as
long as they're not violence I'm a
radical pluralist and we'll have you
know as long as from violent will have
fundamentalist Christian communities
Mormon communities radical yeah you know
all sorts of different people as long as
I live as long island yeah but we gotta
have the big violence before we get
there so well we'll let you have Fight
Club you can have your little fight
there we go okay this has been so
fascinating I'm just I'm so in love with
with your passions and your mind and you
I love what you're building it's so so
important Academy of thought industry
guys check it out below I'll just
quickly quickly on the way out this is a
simulation so we must ask you are we in
a simulation for me it's all very real
there's nothing simulated I love reality
it's a base reality then it's a
beautiful reality or here we are
creating reality this is where I'm a big
believer in creativity so the world I
just described we can create and by
means of talking about it we're gonna
help create it yes or we can let all
those people with a lot of hostile
negatives so one more thing because
you're into creation and earlier you
talked about new concepts neologisms and
so forth I am very interested in the
notion that as we develop new concepts
if they map onto reality we can great
new things so the notion of innovations
and law governance the notions of
innovation in the culture more young
people talking about these things in you
exactly you know as an entrepreneur I
see four stages there's fantasy
is vision there's game plan and then
there's execution yeah yeah and a lot of
you know people drinking bars and do the
fan ideas but I'm very interested in the
transition from fantasy to visions and
envisioned a plan and boom let's do it
that's such a good one I love it okay
okay and last question is what is the
most beautiful thing in the world
obviously my wife and the truth are good
in the beautiful yeah I'm the politeness
to heart yeah
we can do this we can do this and have
fun doing the other people have fun yeah
again that's the thing is all these
people come in from anger and hatred and
negativity I feel sorry for them you
know I have so much fun but going in and
talking with kids about yes ideas and
and seen their joy you know I want
parents to have fun talking to there is
no all of this is easy if we transition
you know the pasta sounds weirdo to go
to 10 days and say nothing fun is a
different word but I long for that way
it done right what is good for us is
joyful and enjoyable so I'm not happy
when you know I'm eating things that are
bad for me and you know bad habits bad
habits aren't ultimately not fun but
part of this is culture I would say my
friends go out for beer I go out for
beer with my friends do yoga I go for
yoga so I even I mean I'm I think the
social thing so we've blamed teens you
teens ought to be better now let's put
them in a culture what's normal so let's
create cultures where it's normal to be
good and nice and entrepreneurially
creative and all that then it happens
it's tricky how to create the cultures
but if we can do this big when
we're gonna have a fun and playful time
building future there we go I love it
Michael is such a pleasure so wonderful
Alan wonderful oh my gosh
okay keep building keep going everyone
please go and check out the links below
to Academy of thought in industry also
check out the conscious capitalism link
also check out Michael's books as well
the link to his books are down a link to
his link dins down there
thank you Ron Vargas are producing and
directing we love you very much give us
your thoughts on the calm in the
comments and in our public telegram the
links below let's get talking about
these things let's get talking about how
to get the youth having these Socratic
dialogues with each other about wanting
to talk about ideas and bring them into
the world also support the artists and
entrepreneurs that you believe in go and
support them our links are below if you
believe in us help us expand it and grow
and prosper help out your communities
bring that forth and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we love you so much thank
you and we will see you soon peace
wonderful that's it
[Music]